I think cars should come with
health warnings like cigarettes.
Why?
Consider this…
What cigarette do you smoke doctor?
It might sound incredible now,
but there was a time when
doctors appeared in adverts
encouraging us to smoke.
You could smoke in restaurants
and pubs, buses and planes.
Now, cigarette packets come
with stark and graphic warnings
about the impact of smoking on your
health - and on those around you.
In the future, will we look back
on this era - the rise of the car -
with similar incredulity?
I think so.
During the height of the
coronavirus lockdown,
daily emissions of carbon dioxide
fell by 17% around the world.
Seventeen million tonnes less
carbon dioxide was emitted every day,
with almost half of that drop
because of fewer car journeys.
Air pollution in some UK cities
dropped by as much as 60%.
There are more than a billion
cars around the world.
And as we reassess
and restructure our world,
I think we need to reassess
our relationship -
you could call it a love affair -
with the car.
What’s interesting about our response
to the threats from both
smoking and the pandemic,
is how we acted and
changed our behaviour
to help protect each other’s health.
We don’t blow cigarette smoke
in each other’s faces anymore.
Or light up inside.
With the coronavirus, we quickly
learned to give each other space,
wear masks, wash our hands -
and we got used to all the signs
reminding us to do so.
It’s normal when
there’s a threat to life
for us to change our behaviour
and to do whatever it takes
to protect friends,
family and other people.
So why do we put up with
the air pollution pandemic,
when there’s something
that we can do about it?
Why don’t we have reminders on cars
about the consequences
of street level pollution,
and encourage us
to walk or cycle more?
Still not convinced?
Here are a few things you need to
be aware of when it comes to cars.
Studies have shown air pollution -
much of which comes from cars -
contributes to the
premature deaths
of almost half a million people
in Europe every year.
The impact on our bodies
is truly frightening.
Air pollution can trigger heart
attacks, strokes, and asthma,
and contribute to stunted growth,
low birth weight, and lung cancer.
Car tyre wear also contributes
hugely to air pollution,
but it’s a largely unregulated area.
As you drive on the road,
your car tyres shed tiny bits
of tyre material - microplastics -
which get washed into our drains,
and ultimately
our rivers and oceans.
This happens regardless of whether
your car is diesel, petrol,
hybrid, or electric.
And there’s another
big problem with cars -
and that’s their impact
on climate change.
You only have to drive 500 metres
in an average modern car
to melt at least
1 kilo of glacier ice.
Since 2010, SUVs have been
the second biggest source
of rising carbon emissions.
If SUV drivers were a nation,
they’d be the world’s 7th biggest
carbon polluter.
Every time you use your car,
you’re contributing to the
degradation of the planet.
A lot of this is just unnecessary.
Here in the UK,
even when trips are only between
one and two miles long - 3km -
six out of 10 people still drive.
In circumstances no-one would
ever have wished for,
the coronavirus pandemic
gave us a small glimpse
of what a different - cleaner,
greener, less polluted, world -
could be like.
Putting health warnings on cars
could be a stark and clear
visual reminder to all of us
about the devastating impact they
have on both people and the planet.
And help shift our attitude
to cars once and for all.